[Music]
life's not about going
life's about going yeah
and and
making sure you keep that in in
all aspects of your life yeah dude
that's what we should put on our that's
what it should have been on the merch
like if you're hitting some girl from
the back like you're not gonna go
uh nah You're Gonna Go ah
oh sorry it was that good for you
usually I can a little longer but uh
today it was like ah sorry
yeah
damn
all it takes is going back to the
apartment and [ __ ] gets sentimental and
deep so people will start crying after
this
too bad this isn't coming out so yeah
yeah this has just gone into The Ether
I'm recording this yeah it it's pretty
crazy you know do you remember when we'd
be in the DDP and you'd be like who
knows we'll be doing this in two years
yeah this shit's boring yeah yeah
how wrong you were yeah I know
[Laughter]
I I remember when you said that I was
like damn that's a crazy question
I mean also one thing that we can kind
of reflect on I think is you know now
that we're like a ye or like how long a
year and year and some change into like
building a network how early on we said
that that was a goal of ours and how
much it like didn't happen yeah up until
you know up until it finally ended up
happening which is [ __ ] awesome but
um
I was reflecting on that because I
remember like when we did those you know
those like agent meetings one of those
like big round table meetings and we
were talking about like that was like
one of the main points it's like we want
to build this a podcast Network
and uh it always kind of seemed like
that was a sort of like a pipe dream
that was like unattainable
but again it goes like with what we've
been saying like just butting off a
little bit more than you can chew like
constantly and then trusting that
eventually you'll get there and and
eventually it did
it did happen you know with with
a decent amount of luck and whatever but
it still is like we got
and um there's still more that we want
to do but it's just cool to be to this
point where it's like we have
whatever five shows now six shows
whatever yeah no I I yeah I remember
only like
I remember the conversation we had it
was me you and Kyle
and I remember kicking out I was like
what if we did like a patreon tier where
we kind of piloted like other ideas and
then you were like oh like a network
yeah I was like yeah
and we were both like ah we're like how
do we do that
and then it was just kind of this vague
like yeah yeah that'd be cool yeah and
then we
to stumble into it is pretty wild yeah
just from that conversation to now yeah
is pretty crazy yeah yeah
um
and even the transition like from that
conversation to putting it in front of
agents to
bringing more people to getting the
bigger space it's such a long long
journey yeah it's just crazy yeah I was
actually thinking with
foul tip
I want to do like I'm I might want to do
like guest reporting segments you should
it's like miscellaneous absolutely like
fight reports yeah or something like
that like I think that'd be just because
I like it yes yeah and you should do F1
too I yeah but I don't know Motorsport
is such a
such a niche thing no people love that
[ __ ] I see it everywhere now I mean yeah
I think yeah some type of guest segment
in that way could be I'll come on and do
guest segments but Iron Man
I mean why not
because that really is like a niche nah
dude that one is like mainstream now
it's mainstream yeah no we got to do
joggling reports yes yes
those guys that's such crazy
I forget did you say you can juggle yes
but juggling while moving
I was gonna prove it there's nothing
here I can juggle is there you don't
take these burritos and see how many
eggs just get off
let me wrap it up
that [ __ ] is a thousand percent coming
undone in the air
yeah
dude this is about to be horrible
[Laughter]
oh hey hey
now the act of that while moving forward
okay let me try yeah
that that messes with my brain that was
pretty good right that was great yeah 10
out of 10 bro we got to blow up a car
this year oh no sorry not a car
something that actually goes like out
what like if you blow up a car the
energy it takes to like actually melt
steel yeah yeah and like explode it it's
not that exciting no it's not and like
you can't we can't afford that much
what's something we could blow up
um what I have an idea no I have no
ideas like a photo realistic paper mache
moose yeah yes
yes or a taxidermied yeah
those are pretty expensive man they're
like two grand okay to rent okay
that'd be pretty fun if you rent wait
how do you know that
so remember yeah yeah
so we looked into it okay weirdly oh
damn
that'd be really funny to rent a moose
and blow it up and just file an
insurance claim yeah are bad
dude blackballed from the industry from
what the Taxidermy industry from the
other yeah Taxidermy rental industry
yeah the damn bummer don't let those TMG
guys in your building they're gonna blow
your [ __ ] up yeah we should just take
all our patreon earnings one year and
then just blow it up get everyone to be
mad at us
likes just so like print like or like
take out take the physical cash and
write it on fire let's say we did it for
the art
yeah I want to be like
yeah no no no that would be a pretty
good statement you see guys money
doesn't matter do what you lost people
are like dude I'm sick I could have used
that
oh [ __ ] are bad you [ __ ] we wanted
that bonus episode from four years ago
that's what we wanted
this is it this is it what's something
else we could
Kaboom
um I think like a lobster oh a giant
Lobster yeah that'd be funny as [ __ ]
yeah
or um we're 10 years old dude what would
blowing up like what could we blow up
whatever Lobster most okay what's like a
non-animal it's a human yeah yeah
you see it's tough once you go past
animal there's nothing it's not the fun
here it's nothing funnier than it
[ __ ] is
damn bro
I saw some animal murder this week did
you
someone sent me something there was that
and then this go-kart crash clip
it's like it's pretty popular like a lot
of people have seen it it's like a
family
each one of them spinning out and then
just going into the wall and then the
last person is like flat out on the gas
and just
wait what is it let me just pull it up
okay let's do good
simultaneously yeah we have no media
share because this is just you know it's
old school it's the old schools for
pulling [ __ ] up on our phones
Ryan two hours ago don't forget to talk
about merch hey Ryan you're fired so